six and 0 at home this season.
They can clinch the NFC North
next week for Chicago their
seventh loss in their last
eight games, but they certainly
had some highlights in this
one. And the guys
who sought first, and
Jack and Rodney from Lambeau
Field and Chris thought
that you guys at least Rodney is
to bundled up for what
the weather is at Lambeau Field
here today, guys.
I don't know what the
temperature is, is who feels
like,
hey, Chris Simms. I'm a little
darker to you.
You okay? So brothers getting a
cardigan? Okay
degrees difference between come
here. You what took it over
the top? Was you wearing snow
pants. That was the first time
I'd seen somebody on TV, where's
don't pad? So I love
it. That you're the man. Hey,
I got so many hand. Warmers
stuck to my shoes.
Sunshine around here.
Unbelievable. Is that it was
cold. I've been sweating
the entire game. Let's get into
this game though. Real quick
Rod. It was a slow start at the
beginning and still look like
the Packers were partying away.
The bye week. Would
Think of Aaron Rodgers his
response. After that.
I have a lot of respect for
Aaron Rodgers and what he
brings. I mean, if anybody ever
had a toe, a sore, toe or even
turf toe, you understand how
difficult it is to be out here.
Not only just out here, but in
these frigid temperatures,
the guy has. So I got, I just
have so much respect for him
because he's so tough. And you
see what out Aaron Rodgers.
I don't know where this team
would be without him in Davante
Adams. He had his hands full
there for a little bit that
matchup on the outside before
the flood gates opened. What
happened after that. I thought
Jay,
Allen Johnson did an excellent
job. Probably one of the best
jobs that our quarterback has
done on Davante Adams,
but the adjustment, the Packers
made, they put him in the slot.
And then that's when everything
just started taking off. He
scored a big touchdown and he
had on a bunch of different. Be
catches
Christians. What did you see
from? This Green Bay passing
attack. Once it finally took
liftoff. Well, I think Rodney
hits her at me first off. They
never totally abandon the Run
game, right? So that's the one
thing they
always got for their offense on
that side of the ball, but then
I Specifically to Rogers and
Rodney makes the point. They
move Davante, Adams around to
where you're not, just going to
get a free pass and go. Oh,
you're going to put him outside
here, going to put our best
corner on. You have to go
somewhere else.
Now. They're going to find ways
to get the ball to Adams and
then
within that they're going to
make the defense defend him in
the new spots. He's in, whether
you going to double cover him,
change your game plan and then
that can open up, you know,
other receivers within the
offense, but you know, Rogers
to me right now and I would
put them in the discussion
right at the top with Brady, as
far as As MVP, just has a great
feel of judging the game
overall. You know, he kind of
lets it plays out and get some
feel all wait. We're down by
10. Okay. Now I'll step on the
gas pedal,
start taking some chances, be
aggressive throwing
the football, but his
connection. I think to allude to
what Rodney
sang with Davante Adams. I don't
know if there's a better
connection in the NFL. As far as
just
one guy, get it into the other
guy
every week and then of course,
them coming up with place to
put them in good situations as
well.
That's right. Is telepathic
communication those to have us
wean, a rod, and Davante Adams,
that friendship. I think plays
into that as well as pretty
amazing though to watch
the start of the
second half where they went to
that power running game, right
round when they came out. It's a
JJ Dillon, right down
the field. I'm going to get him
out. Get one of the best
running backs in the league and
Jones into the game to go.
Finish it off.
They did. Just that. Why was
that the perfect
adjustment coming out in the
second half? I thought, AJ
Dylan,
we talked about in the pregame
show.
I thought, Matt Le Flore does a
really good job of rotating
these guys and not really, just
allowed. Now, these guys to get
tired or anything like that, and
they're healthy. So when
you look at AJ Dillon, man, he's
big, he's physical, who
wants to hit a 250-pound back in
these frigid temperatures.
I'll
tell you it's tough man. And we
talked about, in the pregame
show. Also him taking that
physicality to the next level,
and he showed it tonight, that
boy was running. Did you see
a world where they could get
both of those guys on the field
at
the exact same time?
Mike put Aaron Jones in the
slot. He's another playmaker.
I don't care if he's a running
back. He's a playmaker. Put AJ
Dillon in the bag. Those are
headaches for the defense
Christians. What do you think
about that? Getting a boat in
the game collectively and
having the ability to use him
there in the slot talking about
Aaron? Joe. I would love that. I
think, I think it's
a phenomenal idea. A little bit
of like what the 49ers do
already, right? I mean, you see
them used to running backs on
the field, maybe Debo Samuels at
receiver. All the sudden.
He's at tailback. They move.
Jeff Wilson to slot.
Fever. And he's lead blocking
for Debo Samuel on a toss sweep
or whatever. But to me Rodney
makes a good point. Again.
Jones is very versatile. He's a
big playback. He catch the ball
out of the backfield.
He catches a, you know, a crack
in the seam
and he can run for a 70-yard
touchdown. Now, he's not
necessarily going to get you the
tough yards and I think
that's what Rodney's talking
about with AJ Dillon. That's
greatest when nothing's there.
JJ Dillon, could still Smash It
Up This in there and still get
45 yards
when the defense actually wins
the play
but more weapons.
In the field for a Green Bay
offense that I still think
lacks big-time weapons. They
execute, they don't waste plays
on the offensive side of the
ball. But man
Aaron Jones is kind of that
versatile guy Rodney to your
point that could play slot
receiver running back. You
don't know what to expect. He'll
be able to block a little
before AJ Dillon, in the Run
game or vice versa.
I would like to see it and I
would think it's something they
would toy around with, as the
season goes on. They usually
steal a few plays from Shanahan.
The 49ers. I wouldn't
be shocked if you see.
That come about at some point.
Those are the facts right there,
Chris.